you mentioned mit
is being added to librex has it already
been added yes it was added
um today today okay so let me ask you
this is exciting
because um i don't know what your
thoughts are about
this but i'll tell you from my
perspective if you're
and a lot of mit folks listen to this i
would love it if you join librex
it'd be interesting to explore
conversations
on several topics inside mit but one of
the
most moving
that hasn't been discussed at all
except in little flourishes here and
there
is a topic of jeffrey epstein
now there's been a huge amount
of like impact that
uh the connections of various faculty to
jeffrey epstein
and the various things that been said
had on mit
but it feels like the difficult
conversation haven't had been
had it's the administration trying to
clean up and give a bunch of bs to try
to pretend like let's just hide this
part
like nothing is broken nothing to see
here there's a bad dude that did some
bad things
and uh some faculty that kind of uh
misbehaved a little bit because they're
a little bit clueless let's
let's all look the other way harvard did
this much better by the way
they completely
it's almost like people pretend like
harvard didn't have anything to do with
jeffrey epstein
but i think i'd be curious
to to hear what those conversations are
because uh
the there's conversations on the topic
of like
uh well obviously sort of sexual assault
and disrespecting women on any kind of
level within academia but just women in
general
that's an important topic to talk about
various many
sets of difficult conversations and the
other topic
is um you know funding
uh for research like how are like
what are we okay taking money from and
whether we're not okay taking money from
you know a lot there's a lot of just
interesting difficult conversations to
be had
i've worked with people who you know
refuse to take money from dod department
of defense for example
because in some indirect or direct way
you're funding military
industrial complex all those kinds of
things i think with jeffrey epstein it's
even more
stark this contrast of like well what is
and isn't ethical to take money from and
i just think
forget academia i think there's just a
lot of interesting
deep human discussions to be had and
they haven't been
and there's been somebody i don't know
if you're familiar with eric weinstein
who has been outraged by the fact that
nobody's talking about jeffrey epstein
nobody's having these difficult
conversations and eric himself has had
a sort of complicated journey
through academia uh in the sense that
he's a really kind of renegade thinker
in many kinds of ways i'm not sure if
you
know who eric is by any chance heard the
name okay i actually uh
checked out zev it was heartening for me
to see that i was not the youngest
person
on the street on the yeah
that's hilarious uh
but uh but but eric has he's kind of a
renegade thinker he's a
mathematical physicist uh with a
believer phd in harvard
and he spent some time at mit and so on
but he
he speaks to the fact that sort of
there's a culture of conformity and so
on and if you
if you're somebody who's a bit outside
of the box a bit weird and whatever
dimension of weird
that makes you actually kind of
interesting that the system kind of
wants to make you an outcast wants to
throw you out and so he kind of opposes
that whole idea
so he's the perfect person to have
conversations with in this kind of
librex
kind of context of uh anonymity so yeah
i in that sense i'll talk to eric about
it too
um he probably is unaware of librex we i
believe he still has a harvard email
and an mit email so it'd be fun to kind
of see both of us dive in and see
what that conversation actually uh looks
like and when people are thinking about
it
because uh i'll tell you the few
conversations that came across
and there were very quickly silenced
and i'm troubled by it i'm not sure what
to think
of it is there's a few um threads inside
mit
like on a mailing list discussing
uh marvin minsky i don't know if you
know how that is he's an ai researcher
he's a summonable figure and
before your time but one of the most
important people in art
in the history of artificial
intelligence and uh there was a
discussion on a on a
on a thread that involved
uh the interaction between marvel minsky
and jeffrey epstein
that conversation was quickly shut down
one person was pushed out of mit richard
stallman who's one of the key figures in
the
because of that because he wanted some
clarity
about the situation but he also mis
he spoke like we mentioned earlier with
our grace
right but he was quickly punished for
the administration
uh because of a few people protesting
and just that conversation
uh i guess what bothered me most is it
didn't continue
it didn't it didn't expand there was no
like
complexity and and it was there was a
hunger
that was clear behind that conversation
especially sort of for me
i'd like to understand marvin minsky was
one of the one
one of the reasons i wanted to come to
mit uh he's passed away
but he's one of the key figures in the
field that i deeply care about our
artificial intelligence and i
thought that his name was dragged
through the mud
through that situation and without ever
being like
resolved and so it's unclear to me like
what am i supposed to think about all
this
and and the only way to
come to a conclusion there is to keep
talking
it's like the thing we started this
conversation with about truth
it's like is conversation so in that
sense and
i'd love uh if people on librex
perhaps in other places but it seems
like librex is a nice platform to
discuss marvel minsky to discuss
jeffrey epstein to learn from it to grow
from it to see how we can make mit
better
as i'm still one of the people i've
always dreamed of being at mit
it was a dream come true in many ways
and i still believe
that mit is one of the most special
places in this world
like many other universities
universities in general this is truly
special man
i you know it hurts my heart when people
speak
poorly of academia i understand what
they mean uh they're very correct
but there is much more in my opinion
that's beautiful about academia
and that's broken i mean i don't know if
uh you have something to comment
either it doesn't necessarily need to be
about jeffrey epstein but
there's these difficult things that come
up that
test the academic community right
that it feels like conversation is the
only way
to resolve it i think people have a
natural need for closure
and it's not just i'm not as plugged
into the what academics are talking
about as
you would be lex but even kids these
days
no respect for minsky exactly i mean
especially in the ai community i'm i'm
not not necessarily a programmer
um but what i will say is that um
people come to librex and we always see
a huge spike in
users whenever there's like a tragedy on
campus or something where people need
closure
um recently there was a suicide just the
other day
on yale's campus and people are just
coming to pay respects and to
stay rest in peace and speak also about
what might have led to an environment
where people
are drawn to these terrible
results um so just having a conversation
is important there because it like it
brings you
people need the space especially when
no one wants to go out and put their
head above you know be the longest
blade of grass on that one yeah because
of the stigma
yeah people need to be able to speak
yeah that fear really bothers me the
fear that silences people like
were they self-censored were they
self-silence
well i'm um
you've created an amazing place i i'm
kind of interested
in your struggle and your journey of
creating positive
incentives because uh it's a problem
in a very different domain that i'm also
interested in
um so i you know i love about robotics i
love human robot interaction
and so i believe that most people are
good and we can bring out the best in
human nature
social networks is a very tricky space
to do that in so i'm glad you're taking
on the problem and i'm glad you have the
mission that you do
i hope you succeed
you